what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay what is going on guys this is Rob
and I'm sure you guys are excited about
the Black Panther movie that's coming
out at least I know I am and I have no
idea when I'm releasing this video
probably this weekend but I am really
excited about the whole Black Panther
film and so I had my writer Ryan the
same guy who wrote the script on
omega-level Beyond omega-level pickle
rick i had him write up a script i'm
Wakonda explained the problem is that
Ryan has been derelict in his duties and
he has not written up anything about the
door of melash a so now I've got
explained the door balagia off top my
head which is kind of a problem but
anyway so the door Milosh a in in Marvel
Comics they exist in two forms there is
the way they used to exist and then
there's the way they exist now so the
way it used to be in Wakanda is not
every tribe felt like they were
receiving like adequate representation
when it came to you how they were viewed
by the black panther at the time the the
sitting king of Wakanda and so there was
some measure of like civil discourse it
wasn't like very many tribes had the
gumption to like openly revolt against a
sitting King but there would be things
where they would they would promote like
small little rebellions here and there
or at least there was fear of open
rebellion and so what ended up happening
is one of the Black Panthers I don't
number which a one of the Black Panther
is basically christened or created
something called the Dorma logic and
what would happen is that each one of
these tribes in Wakanda would put
forward their most beautiful daughter
potentially to become the wife of Black
Panther the problem with this is that
they would serve in a couple capacities
if one of the doormen ashay was chosen
to become a wife then the others were
chosen to become bodyguards but because
no one door Milosh a new or no one of
these women knew if they would be a
bodyguard or a wife they were all
trained to become bodyguards now of
course it would serve very little
purpose to have a bodyguard for Black
Panther that basically gets defeated
really fast like that'd be kind of
useless that'd be kind of pointless and
so what ended up happening is all the
door Milazzo were basically trained to
become like these elite assassins and
they are hard core I mean they're like
the best warriors that the Black Panther
has at his side now the idea was that
with one of those door Milan che
becoming becoming the wife of the Black
Panther they would still be exceedingly
good at combat because you know they
were trained to potentially become a
bodyguard but after a while that trend
kind of died off it eventually sort of
went away and it was considered to be
archaic of an older time now T'Challa
brought the trend back the difference
here is that he did not intend to marry
anybody inside of Wakanda
and Black Panther vol 3 there was a girl
it was I want to say it was something
Lin or like Len D or something along
those lines ah Christopher priest wrote
in a character the Black Panther
proposed to but she was an outsider she
was not part of what Condon heritage and
so in order to basically appease all
these different tribes that felt like
they were being left out he reinstated
the whole idea of the dorm aloshy but he
ultimately ended up viewing them as like
daughters as opposed to potential wives
and this kind of segue into him marrying
storm who was from Africa but not
actually from what conduct she was from
the Serengeti and so the result was that
the door Milosh they basically were just
kind of maintained as bodyguards as
opposed to potential wives but it did
serve his purpose because the various
tribes felt like they were being
adequately represented in the Wakanda
royal family as opposed to just kind of
being left out and so that's basically
the nature of how the door Milosh they
came into existence and what they're
capable of now on to Wakanda itself so
well Conda is a country in northeastern
Africa and is borderline by Ethiopia and
Uganda and Kenya and Somalia and a
fictional nation of Nairobi
now in terms of its real-life origin
while Conda was created by Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby and first appeared in
Fantastic Four number 52 in 1966 however
what we do know about what countess
history within the Marvel Universe goes
back much much farther to a man named
bazinga who was the first King to rule
over Wakanda and the first person to
become Black Panther all of which
happened around 10,000 years ago now as
a side note here I think it's important
to explain that while the Black Panther
is the name by which to chala uses when
he operates as a superhero it's actually
a ceremonial title given to the chief of
the Panther cult which we'll dive into
in more detail here in a second but
without a doubt the most significant
event to ever happen to the to the
country of Wakanda was a meteorite
crashing and bringing with it a vast
deposit of vibranium to Wakanda itself
and so vibranium for those guys who
don't know is one of these strongest and
hardest metals in the Marvel Universe
and is able to absorb all sound waves
and vibrations as well as amplify
magical energy
now predictably these properties make
vibranium a highly sought-after
commodity within the Marvel Universe now
that a positive vibe rhenium in Wakanda
was first discovered by bazinga who
subsequently sealed it off because he
some of the people who discovered it
along with him were exposed to the
radiation and they became what fishing
referred to as like demon spirits they
basically turned on other wakandans now
over the course of the next several
centuries vibranium was would
effectively become the lifeblood that
sustained
condon economy King to Chaka who is the
father of T'Challa actually sold off
small quantities of vibranium and used
the money to fund education for citizens
as well as the technological advancement
of Wakanda itself but after - Chuck had
died
T'Challa took over became the new black
panther and actually ended his father's
policy of isolation from the rest of the
world and began selling larger
quantities of vibranium to buyers that
he was sure would not use it for a
nefarious purposes now because of all
the money that what Conda made from the
sale of their vibranium over the years
they've developed into one of the most
technologically advanced countries in
the world and the richest country in the
world to give you guys some some some
some perspective here vibranium sells
for about ten thousand dollars a gram
now if there's around ten thousand tons
of vibranium in Wakanda then we could
say about two thousand pounds per ton so
that's about twenty million times or
twenty million pounds roughly and then
you multiply that times 453 that's nine
billion something and then multiply each
one of those by ten thousand to nellen
dollars so that comes I would say comes
out to be something like ninety trillion
dollars or something it comes out to be
an insane amount of money like it's
ridiculous uh assuming that's right it's
we my math is right then that would mean
that what conda's value is higher than
the rest of the world's gross domestic
product which is to say the value of all
the goods and services any one
particular country can offer I would say
as it stands right now at least last I
read in 2016 the GDP of the world was
like seventy five trillion dollars which
means that if this is true what conda's
GDP is worth fifteen trillion dollars
more than the rest of the world combined
which is pretty bonkers when you think
about it but regardless of the scenario
there are 800 examples of wakandan
technology using vibranium throughout
the entirety of Wakanda itself for
example there is a jungle that blankets
Wakanda that was engineered by T'Challa
and actually sort of blends in vibranium
seamlessly with the jungle itself so
it's actually pretty cool there are
aircraft powered by magnets called
magnetic wave riders that are capable of
transcontinental travel with in Wakanda
itself and wakanda's also developed
devices known as hollow pods which
create holographic duplicates of their
users now there is also a great deal
more technology in Wakanda that goes on
as well but most of that scan find a
black panthers own suit which will
actually cover in a video later on but
the most interesting thing about what
Conda is that on one hand you
have this super advanced and super
wealthy country in the middle of Africa
which steps it apart from the rest of
the continent but on the other hand the
people of Wakanda still follow extremely
faithfully the tribal religions of their
ancestors so for that reason I think in
order to fully understand what kannada
itself we're gonna have to go and have a
discussion on some of the major
religious groups that are present there
which are referred to in comics as cults
but really you could call them clans if
you wanted to and so the basis of the
wakandan religion is actually pretty
interesting as it dates back to
Stanley's work with Marvel's predecessor
Atlas comics in 1950 now in issue number
96 of the series Marvel tales Stan Lee
created a pantheon of gods known as the
Helio polit ins which are based on the
deities of each and Egypt now sixteen
years later Stanley would introduce one
of these deities known as bast the
Panther God and those who worship bast
make up the Panther cult which traces
itself all the way back to bazinga
himself now the Panther call persists as
the most widely followed an official
state religion even today some ten
thousand years after it was originally
founded now when a Black Panther dies a
new one has to be crowned you cannot
have a vacant throne in Wakanda a new
Black Panther has to be chosen and while
this is a hereditary title the one
assuming the role must prove themselves
worthy simply meaning that it's not like
a monarchy it's not like a Black Panther
dies and a new one just ascends to the
throne you have to prove yourself worthy
and to do this you have to be invited to
take part in the eating of something
this called a heart-shaped herb now the
heart shaped curve is a plant that's
native to Wakanda and is thought to be
or at least what's thought to be a gift
from bast to the various followers of
the Panther cult but in reality this
isn't true it's basically a plant that
was just a radiated by vibranium
radiation that's really all it is but
the herbed of a does give its user
extraordinary strength and agility
now after eating the herb the aspiring
Black Panther has to defeat six of
wakanda's best warriors in combat all at
the same time in order to prove
themselves worthy now this is of course
assuming a black panther has died if a
person chooses to challenge a black
panther they have to consume the
heart-shape herb then they have to fight
the Black Panther then they have to
defeat six of his best warriors all at
the same time and the caveat to all this
is that if the heart-shaped herb rejects
you then you'll die but although the
Black Panther cold is the dominant
religion in Wakanda it's not the only
one other cults also exist or have
existed at some point in time there's
sworn to serve the other Helio politan
deities for example there is the defunct
crocodile called that once worship the
crocodile god Sobek
but this faction has been white boy
ELISA was wiped out after they
resurrected the villian more Lund in
hopes of overthrowing the Black Panther
and then more lund basically turned on
all of them and killed them all
immediately after coming back to life
those guys you don't know who more lund
is Marvel Comics established there are
what are called totems beings that
represent animals more or less and more
lawn is an inherited what this means is
that if a person draws their power from
an animal more Lund can consume that
person's life energy and sustain himself
another mine are called is the lion cult
which worships the god is segment but
basically all we know about this cult is
that it was once a lot more popular than
the Panther cult in Wakanda but almost
all the followers of the lion cult
defected and joined the Panther cult but
finally there is probably the most
significant cult that exists outside of
the Panther cult which is the white
gorilla cult which worship the gorilla
God
gert at least I think that's how you
pronounce it is Kurt but once the
Panther called rose to prominence the
worship of this God the the white
gorilla God was outlawed in its entirety
but some followers still practice their
faith in areas of Wakanda the most
notable of which was called Jabari
village which was ruled over by Amanda
was only known as the white gorilla
now why gorillas actually hated Black
Panther uh largely because white panther
wouldn't share his wealth with the other
tribes in Wakanda with these other cults
and so as a result during World War two
what gorillas actually formed an
alliance with family friendly term for
the German military group led by a
dictator and in turn led an entire
attack on Wakanda itself now of course
he was ultimately defeated alongside the
efforts of Captain America because you
know I mean it's world war two you and
Captain America and you know so on and
so forth but the white gorilla cult did
not actually die with its leader and
would actually we emerge under the
leadership of a guy named mbaku mbaku
was basically the greatest released the
second greatest warrior in in Wakanda a
second to T'Challa and would actually
appear or at least will actually appear
in the Black Panther movie as well as
Avengers infinity war would suggest that
what Caan is going to play a huge role
in this phase of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but Walter Chawla was gone from
Wakanda for an extended sabbatical mbaku
calling himself man a panic
I can almost guarantee they won't use in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe for a
variety of reasons actually revives the
white gorilla called
and then claims the throne of Wakanda
for himself now to help him accomplish
this mbaku kills one of the rare white
gorillas living in the Wakanda jungle
and then as weird as this sounds bathes
in its blood and then eats his flesh
which gives him the gorillas strength
and so ultimately as you may have
guessed mbaku was beaten by black
panther and exiled from what conduct
something that I do want to point out
here most likely what will happen with
Manny I have no doubt that Erik kill
monger will most likely be killed in
Black Panther the movie which kind of
sucks because I really hope that doesn't
happen I think that Eric he'll monger is
actually a far more interesting villain
than man ape is most likely what will
happen here if mbaku if man is supposed
to appear in infinity war what will
likely take place is Black Panther will
have to leave Wakanda in order to
partake in the infinity war battle when
that happens man ape will most likely
make his move and take over Wakanda in
two challahs absence so that the child
will come back and have to deal with
regaining his country in the midst of a
revolution that's most likely what will
happen I don't see any reason why
anything other than that would happen
but yeah that's pretty much a coverage
on all the major stuff of Wakanda
there's small little tidbits here and
there and we'll talk about stuff like
Black Panthers suit things like that
we'll talk about that in a later video
but if you guys are new here to come
this explain make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the Rob
pork if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you